hello everybody and welcome to the third
Q&A the theme for this Q&A is don't
worry be hacky but first
mail time also some people have asked me
for a mailing address you can use this
mailing address and you can get to me
that is a P o box however so don't send
me something huge so this is the first
thing I'm pretty sure I know what this
is oh my gosh I got a bunch of stuff
that's stickers from Alexa goodness
handwritten note as well from my good
friends at Amazon so Amazon sent me a
full-sized
echo after seeing my review of the echo
dot so now I'll actually be able to
compare the dot to the full-sized
full-sized echo pretty cool anyway
enough on that you'll see more on that
if you follow the Alexa series next up
something you all have been a part of
one fact I want stabbed myself with this
lovely Leatherman had to get some
stitches was a fun day real fun I go
another letter fantastic fantastic so if
you don't know when you get certain
subscriber levels on YouTube they send
you a plaque of sorts for your efforts
and this is my play button for 100,000
subscribers very cool so at a hundred
thousand subscribers you get a plaque I
forgot I'm not sure what color this is
if it's supposed to be silver or what I
think you get like a silver silver
button for a hundred thousand you get a
gold button I think for a million then
maybe a platinum button for ten million
I can't remember but anyways you get in
for various levels this is actually
pretty nice it's like a depth frame and
everything that's pretty fancy although
they should I have made Google a fair
amount of money so I guess that's the
least they could do so thank you to all
of you especially my subscribers without
you it literally would not have been
possible so I remember like my first 100
subscribers like wondering who are these
people that are looking at my content
and are like yeah I want more that let
me know when you put more of those out
No so anyway that brings us to the theme
again of this video which is don't worry
be hacky otherwise if you're familiar
with maybe Guy Kawasaki version don't
worry be crappy basically the same kind
of idea to live by so I get a lot of
questions like how did you get started
doing tutorials when did you start
feeling comfortable teaching Python when
did you or how did you go about actually
starting a business with Python and and
being self-employed and all those kinds
of things and how long till you started
feeling basically like an expert in
Python or something like that you know
these kinds of questions are
get all of the time so first of all I
still don't consider myself to be an
expert in Python I'm putting out the
intermediate series that's that's where
I am right I consider myself an
intermediate Python developer so I'm not
an expert by any means and basically
eventually you just kind of come to the
realization that like anything you put
out onto the Internet there are going to
be people that dislike it or don't or
are mean to you or whatever but for the
most part everyone is overwhelmingly
positive again I was putting out some
pretty bad videos initially just
horrible filming quality horrible audio
quality the tutorials and like the
technique actually used was pretty bad
just all of those things I was putting
out overall pretty good content which
you can actually go see you can go to my
channel sort videos by date and you can
look at all the nasty stuff I had going
on I don't think I've removed but maybe
a few videos the only videos I'll ever
really delete from YouTube are like
videos that I don't I really don't want
people to find because it's teaching
something just a very bad bad technique
or something like that if it's just not
showing the best technique or something
like that I don't care I'll leave it but
if there's something really wrong with
what I'm doing I'll remove that just so
someone does not think that oh yeah I'll
just do that right so so some things
have been removed but you can feel free
to go through like my first few hundred
videos they're not that great hello and
welcome to my tutorial on encryption
with Python so a lot of you probably
haven't been following me since I
started the YouTube channel so I started
the YouTube channel you can go to my
channel and find I was like I think late
December 2012 and I started programming
in Python I'm pretty sure if I recall
right at the late end of 2011 maybe
sometime in 2012 so ballpark maybe I've
been programming Python now for about
five years something like that probably
even less but somewhere around there and
the whole time has just been just one
gigantic learning journey
but one thing has stayed the same
throughout and then that and that's that
if you're willing to share knowledge
people are just going to appreciate it
so there are going to be people are
going to be mean maybe or poke fun or
whatever but that's like the really
really true minority like maybe 1% of
people or something like that and as the
channel grows that 1% becomes a bigger
number but for the most part like it's
just overwhelmingly positive when you're
putting out information and trying to
help people
most people will respect that so you
know how do you start being a teacher or
whatever doing tutorials just start you
turn on the camera or you turn on your
screen recorder and you just start
talking some stuff and doing some stuff
and sharing your information I think
that everyone should do it if you want
to learn it's a great way to learn and
like I was saying and I'm pretty sure
the first Q&A basically it just
reinforces what you already know and
shines light on what you don't know and
usually that will happen before you
publish a video is long or a tutorial or
whatever as long as you're going through
maybe you're let's say you're using a
method or a function or something like
that and you're writing in the
parameters and you can't explain to your
viewer what those parameters are doing
every single one of them you need to go
back and figure it out right it's just a
really great way to learn things and I
think that's why this channel has been
successful is I just I explain like
everything and also I'm not some sort of
expert programmer that comes to it
having all this prior knowledge I know
exactly what it's like to be learning
this stuff because I'm learning this
stuff I share it pretty much immediately
once I've learned something I'm going to
come to YouTube and I share it right
that's just that's just the way I've
always done it so I'm very close in
proximity to my viewers who are viewing
the content for the first time I
remember what it was like the first time
I came across this and a great example
of where this can fall short is like the
beautiful soup series that I just
recently put out now so far no one's
really like raised the point which kind
of surprised me but after I published
the series I realized I never even
explained like tags quick HTML tags okay
I showed people how to use beautiful
soup and I
show them examples in parsing tags but I
never actually explained how tags work
and you've got the opening and the
closing and what individual tags might
even be the paragraph tags body tags all
this kind of stuff I never fully
explained that that's something that a
newcomer watching that video is going to
be like wait what what the hell is this
stuff right if you don't know those tags
that's confusing that's a perfect
example of it's just been well overdue
for me to do a beautiful soup tutorial
and I'm doing it now after the fact with
all this prior knowledge that I have but
not everyone else has luckily like I
said it doesn't seem like that's been a
problem but after I publish it I was
like oh I should explain those things as
for starting businesses that one's a
little harder but still it's don't worry
be crappy for the most part in fact
that's how Guy Kawasaki use is that
usually it's in terms of startups and
stuff like that but it's just make a
product put it out there have a short
feedback loop something like YouTube or
a code review it's a really short
feedback loop put something out show it
to your users get feedback from your
users make those changes whatever needs
to be changed so with any sort of
product the thing the thing you've got
to do is just always be producing and
putting content out there or a product
out there whatever it might be getting
feedback from the user and implementing
that feedback as it goes and that's
really just the biggest thing I think a
lot of people are just afraid of what
what people might think
and that's holding them back because
they're worried about what people might
think but the only way you can find out
what people actually think is to put
something in their hands or in further
eyeballs or whatever and see what they
think right so you just got to do it I
remember like the first few times I
shared a like post on Reddit or
something I was like oh my gosh what if
I get down voted it's like what if I get
down okay it's like it really just
doesn't matter and in turn the only
place it might matter is in a business
setting you don't want to be crappy and
hacky especially if you've got a
long-term client and they're trusting
and relying on you you don't to be
totally a piece of junk but when you're
just starting out how to get started
that's my suggestion don't worry about
it be hacky be crappy
do those things and you will either be
successful or at least you will figure
out what you need to do to be successful
so anyways I think that's enough for
this Q&A if you have any further Q&A
questions feel free to leave them below
if I have an answer your Q&A question
yet you don't have to remind me I have
them all basically in a big ol file and
I'm just kind of going through and
aggregating them that are fairly similar
like this one I got a lot of questions
on things that are pretty much all the
same in terms of just don't worry about
it just do it so yeah anyway questions
comments below otherwise I'll see you in
the next video